hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Ark the survival
shall continue and I shall not be
thwarted in my quest because I've got a
full belly and apparently I've got full
water too because I think I just tilted
my head back and let the gods fulfill my
thirst and then um then I guess my
energy is all good - and my warmth is
not doing so bad so the only thing that
I don't have is fiber and it's the dead
of night and there's a weird glowy thing
over there I don't know what the hell
that is but I'm gonna go towards it if
there's other players I'm gonna talk to
them and they're talking about shoving
qex in each other's mouths I don't
exactly know what that means but I'm
gonna try my best to survive that's all
I know how to do and that's all I will
do I've got some food I've got the will
I've got the wherewithal and all that
kind of please thank you
I'm ready no fine
what's a list Oh what are you whoa who's
there whoa hello you want to go yo you
want to go oh you're gonna go you're
gonna go to hell - I don't know where
you are but I'm beating the [ __ ] out of
the darkness damn it okay you're just
whoa hey there's a lot of you all right
okay all right then you know what you're
not even worth my time that's what I'm
gonna say is Mike's you hey is that a
bigger one I don't know what that is but
it looks kill we hello hi how are you
who are you
are you tamed what are your bigger than
who you keep it you just keep growing I
[ __ ] my pants because I was so scared
what's up Frick is going on here you
stuck
oh you're bigger than I thought you were
alright I don't know where I am and I
don't know what you're doing in that
rock but have fun mating with it I'm
sure it's enjoying it carry on
Who am I to judge I'm new here okay then
we're hey goddamnit come on you still
you still on about that you want it you
want to get some oh I ate it in front of
you is that what you want out these
[ __ ] just won't leave me alone so I
don't know where that light went the
lights seem to have gone okay so I'm
gonna go towards the light and I'm gonna
figure out what this son of a [ __ ] is
all about because if it's something good
for me I want to find it and if it's
something bad for me I want to hit it
head-on before it gets a chance to
retaliate
that looks QE where's this some ruins
no it's an Amer Barry hey fiber oh
that's good cool
all right well that's something at least
oh that looks that looks intense it
seems to be on some sort of a fortress
what the hell happened what happened
right I died from what what it certainly
fell a bird I think someone beat the
[ __ ] out of me but I didn't even notice
it all right Oh people here are a little
little bit rude if you ask me all right
I'm gonna respawn and apparently they
killed me whoever they are and that's
really unfair I think it's a bit douchey
but hey maybe just maybe I still got the
things that I can craft yeah I'm still
the same level that I was and I'm still
the same guy I just need to get some
stuff again so they think they can just
toss me aside and then I'll be gone to
the wind I think not time to punch trees
till I get back on my feet
ah click what the [ __ ] hell is
happening why am i under attack who's
attacking me I can't see [ __ ]
ah it's a male wild wild male
Dilophosaurus I'm out of here
can't see [ __ ] I'm blinded oh boy
I'm blinded I'm blinded I'm blinded why
am i blind that's no good this place is
rough why is this place so mean I just
want to survive I just want to survive
I'll be I don't know what I'm hitting
woo that's a big thing
what are you oh you're big oh you're big
I probably should yeah yeah oh god I'm
blind it again
god damn it well apparently this is the
this is a goddamn episode of death oh
[ __ ] where's the Sun please give me some
Sun damn it oh boy I am oh I am I'm not
where I should be
so mommy dad don't even do it don't even
try
don't try buddies don't try friendos
yeah I don't like that
I am almost dead but you know what I can
live with that
I can live with the fact that I'm almost
dead jeez oh I'm running out of energy
very rapidly
why is the shoreline not getting any
closer oh god oh god oh god I done
goofed didn't I I'm gonna drown Oh No
Oh doh in the darkness it was much
farther away than it looked like it was
Oh No
[Applause]
Oh No Ark survival evolved more like Ark
markiplier sucks up dead feel the cold
embrace death closing in on me I'm gonna
fading fast I barely swept across an
entire ocean to try to get down here I'm
currently drowning can't bathe currently
running out of oxygen oh whoa I [ __ ] my
pants as I exit the river and I'm a-ok
people thought that I was down and out
of my luck little did they know I was
down and out of nothing I leveled up cuz
I [ __ ] myself so good and swam across
that son of a [ __ ] hey you wanna you
want to [ __ ] with me I [ __ ] all over you
alright level it up I'm gonna get more
um-um and get more movement speed hell
yeah I like the sound of that now I
don't need to do that not yet now yeah
and I'm gonna hold off until I actually
know what I'm doing what do I need for a
torch Flint okay I just need to hit a
rock but the problem is I can't see you
goddamn around cuz he's freaking dark I
can't see [ __ ] oh quit fists or torch to
harvest from this oh okay
so yes ah ooh berries I like it oh I'm
grabbing up everything on the ground
hell yeah hell yeah okay so I got
berries huh are they gonna be good for
me I'm gonna eat them they better be
good they better be good alright today
is shining hello son
miss you said a rock I'm gonna hit it
well that's not good
god damn it again with this [ __ ] you
want to go toe-to-toe with me bro you're
gonna go down go down
I'm
go down but you're also gonna go down
out out out out just want [ __ ] Flint
oh [ __ ] now this guy really hurts me
don't know I don't wanna die I wanna
know who I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm out of here give it
up give it up bro I need a spear what I
need to do is I need to make a spear
next oh gotta get big stuff I got a zoom
Barry I got 500k I know how to get fiber
now I know you just sprint madly and
grab everything that you can recklessly
go whoo all right I'm tired I think I
think I think I lost it yeah I think I
lost it okay so I can just stay here for
a bit damn it the [ __ ] are you doing Oh
were you not running for me run you are
no yes I thought you were going for me
bro I [ __ ] myself I was so scared you
know all the Bears I can apparently I
made a primitive stone answer don't know
how that weirdo okay so everybody just
calm down here for a goddamn second I'm
gonna kill this monkey but I need a
better thing to do that I'm gonna make
us all right and then a church all right
and then I got these little berries
özil berries and I got narcho berries
make you sleepy I don't want to do that
I don't want to get slippy all right but
now I've got a spur
so with this spur I'm gonna drive it
into the hearts of my enemies like this
monkey were you out spurred I broke my
spear what are you talking about I broke
my spear a [ __ ] I'm gonna get you if you
can run monkey huh I don't care don't
care don't care don't care don't care
don't care don't care don't care don't
care get monk womp womp in the bog
monkey womp Adama chopper tail off you
think you're gonna go super saiyan Tommy
no
well [ __ ] his body of disappeared into
the rock I needed that I was trying to
get meat from that I wasn't trying to
just send him into the abyss I was
trying to actually get something out of
that anyway I didn't work all right well
I guess I'll up my fortitude that'll be
nice
I think I'll appreciate that ah sleeping
bag sounds good I'm gonna do that uh a
wall or roof ah door ah bad I can't do
that all right I can't do that get it
okay all right I'm gonna make a jump
boots that's good I'm gonna do that okay
so I've got a whole bunch of [ __ ] that I
can do I just need to get the materials
to be able to do it these goddamn
monkeys would stop oh you want to go huh
you're lucky you're lucky this time
good thing I'm gonna go off and get more
resources and scream like a little baby
I need food real bad
I got to go through the bushes that's
why I got do it gotta get this Bush bush
but it's good Bush stim Barry m'angil
Barry oh ooh oh these are gonna be great
berries for me soon
Oh Marburg knocker bird Mitch where's
Jim berries ah ah god damn it stop it
stop with a Fricks
Oh rude Hey okay all right I need to hit
this stuff I need to hit it is that what
does that advice you're giving me I'm
going into the woods where you guys
can't bother me no more you're bothering
me
stop it no
all right anyway I got this guy's
hice ties it down me I got this well you
figure I don't got this huh
you think I don't got this haha you
think I don't got this oh I got this
you just watch me got this cuz now I
know and there's no stopping me
oh what's that I could have read a guide
no that's not how mark a blocker learns
I learned from the Tyler way of learning
I teach with my fists punching one hell
of a hole in them
give me some wood there we go that's
what I need a damn Rock need a damn Rock
need a damn ronk need a damn damn Rock I
seem to be in some sort of marshland now
so I'm going to Don the persona of my
favorite animated actor and channel my
inner Shrek here and I'm gonna build a
home in the swamp the swabs shall be my
home no one shall be allowed in my swamp
my swamp is where my law reigns nobody
shall be able to withstand the power of
my swamp and anybody that dare ya try to
get in my swamp are you a fish out of
water you look like a fish out of water
maybe I could grant you a swift death
I'm gonna get a pic I can make pants
pants and a shirt I can be civilized and
wear clothes I wanna beat the [ __ ] out
of you
or say you can't fight back that's my
favorite type of enemy gonna eat some
berries in the middle of this get a
little hungry when I'm whomping a
helpless fish don't beat the [ __ ] out of
ya it's just gonna happen you better
just lay down all over come on there we
go give me that me go Oh Frick yeah set
another one over there
hey don't worry about it i whistled
apparently I got a beard I'm becoming a
man oh look at me I just want this to
appear in my frame I didn't know I had
such beautiful green eyes beautiful so I
need to use this pack I gotta make
another one eventually that's really
cool though I level up and it's kind of
stays consistent throughout it that's
that's not too bad it's not bad it's not
the worst thing in the world need more
stone for you and me all right the only
thing my swamp does not provide and it
provides a lot don't get me wrong it
provides me almost everything that I
could possibly need for my adventures
but I need to give me some rock yeah oh
this is a good rock quality can you
smell it
can you smell the quality in that rock
that's good Rock and I thought swamp
could not provide Rock it provides the
best Rock the richest Rock the most
enamored Rock yes my ancestors used to
ride these for miles making a spongebob
reference okay doing it guys I'm doing
it who would think they live in a swamp
it's the best place to live you what are
you talking about it's the reject place
- no it wants to build a base it's my
home the swamp is my love a good thing I
got a backup oh that's convenient you
can just press it and it'll craft
nice oh you can repair it oh that's even
better than dropping a new one I guess
ooh pop you okay I'm getting weighed
down a bit I need to thank you all so
are these thorny these hurt me if I run
through it not do get some whoo hey whoo
hey buddy
all right you carry on now you gonna be
my friend bet you will
I bet you will oh hell yeah my pants
ready are my pants ready I bet they are
oh they are legs oh I'm so handsome
oh and dapper oh look at me I'm dapper
oh hell yeah oh you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna make a fat foundation I'm
gonna make a wall I'm gonna make a door
I'm gonna make a roof i'ma make another
wall I'm gonna make a doorframe and then
I'm gonna make a stone hatch hat and
then you know I'm doing surprisingly
ding-dang-dong good for dying twice and
getting to the point where everybody
could get you basically in the game
without trying and I did it so well I'm
proud of myself I mean you guys probably
aren't hey I am okay I'm learning I'm
learning as I go and I think that is
something that ever that is a giant
snake oh my god that is a giant snake
yeah okay
maybe it's her swamp and maybe don't
come near me you snake [ __ ] all right
you slither on out of here you bastard
all right so this seems like you're good
enough place as any to start laying the
foundation down ooh I don't like these
runners okay anyway just gonna do my
thing hopefully they don't bother me
all right so the foundation the walls
the door the door Fran all right ho okay
you carry on jeez um people are not
happy here I need more fortitude
I'll get that stuff later huh god dammit
the snake my torpidity but torpidity is
rapidly drained Oh Oh snake why snack
please I was doing so good okay I think
it left me alone though no did not don't
come after me bro don't come after me
I'm going back in that swamp I'm getting
the Frick away from you yeah get up get
up get up get up come on get up why am I
just on the ground well I mean I got bit
by a snake obviously yeah no no no no no
no oh they're both beating the [ __ ] out
of me
[Applause]
not being yet I'll be right back
be right back guys believe it may please
oh god oh my friend how you doing okay
I've got my pants back I've got my shirt
back I can cover up my gross body and
Venna
what the hell is that what I missing so
I can't build here because apparently
I'm too close to an enemy gate or
something like that I think that's
probably the gate that's a big-ass gate
so I don't know what the hell that big
wire is but I'm gonna keep going a
little oh my god it's the Great Wall
holy [ __ ] Oh what am I looking at here
I don't want to be in here what the [ __ ]
what happened Seeger goddamnit you
pulled my light out why
oh all right everything is fine
deep breaths I can make this I just
gotta make my goddamn base just gonna
make this right here oh yes oh let me
make it here oh yes oh that's oh so good
oh and then yes yes and then eight a
door even oh and then I have a roof I
know I do yes I do
it's it's destiny Oh roof Oh home to
call my own I've done it I've made it
and I think that's a good place to end
the second episode of arc but don't you
worry I've got a lot more to do you see
those empires over there soon they'll be
worshipping me is it God they will erect
monuments to my glory
this patch roof is just the beginning so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for cheering me on like a new
you are in the comments
down below let me know what you think
I'm doing in what my prospects are for
the future as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]